- Busy morning
here on Valentine's Day.
Just got out of a
really intense awesome,
really great actually client
meeting so that's a lot of fun
and so always amazing to have
super smart
clients and fun ideation.
Now headed back to the
office for a bunch of meetings.
Hope everybody is
having a great day
and where's DRock?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- What's up, man?
How you doing?
- Good to see you.
- [Kevin] Good to see you.
- K-Rose.
- [Kevin] 'Sup?
- We about to do this?
- [Kevin] We are.
- [Gary] What's the
name of the podcast?
- The Journal.
- Oh, The Journal.
- Yeah, I'm putting
it under The Journal.
- [Gary] Brian did it?
I saw a picture of him.
- What? Oh yeah, Hoover.
Yeah, he did it.
- Hoovs.
DRock, what are you doing?
- I'm just here.
- Livin' life?
- Yep.
- [Kevin] Alright,
let's get started.
GaryVee!
- Yes sir.
- [Kevin] Dude it
is good to have you.
- It's good to be here, man.
- [Kevin] Why VaynerMedia?
What made you think--
- Well, I think
you remember this.
I think it's actually more
interesting to ask you and
I don't know if you'll remember.
I don't know if it's enough of a
moment for you to remember it.
It's a long time ago.
But I thought everybody,
our whole crew,
Sacca, Morin, Travis,
everybody was weirded out that
AJ and I started VaynerMedia.
'Cause everybody was
building big tech apps and
raising tons of money.
- [Kevin] Actually I wasn't
weirded out by it at all.
- 'Cause you're practical.
To that point, you're practical.
- [Kevin] It plays
to your strengths.
- What I knew was I was building
a foundation for my future.
It wasn't hard for me.
The first 13 years
of my life weren't sexy.
I was quiet and
I built an actual business.
- [Kevin] But how
did you get funding?
External funding?
- Nope, nope.
We landed a
Gillette project for $80,000.
We activated in Vegas, Travis
flew in and slept on our floor
with me and AJ.
- [Kevin] How'd you
meet this first client?
- I met this dude at a
Nets game who had an agency.
It was a subcontracted thing.
And he's like,
"Hey, what do you do?
You're the wine guy?"
I'm like, "No, no, I'm starting
this thing called VaynerMedia."
- [Kevin] And you were doing
talks at this point so you were
gaining some popularity.
- And I was writing Crush It!
- [Kevin] Right.
- This started in May 2009
that came out October so I just
finished writing
that and I just gave--
- [Kevin] But people
hadn't read that yet?
- No, and I just
gave that Web 2.0 talk.
Everybody has time.
Stop watching fucking "Lost."
That blew my whole world up.
- [Kevin] So that
was that the moment.
- No, no, that's the moment.
- [Kevin] Okay.
- There's two moments.
Being on Diggnation
with you and Alex, 100%.
- I love that you guys are like
you is like in press mode with
little Madonna talk.
- I legitimately
feel like Janet Jackson.
That combo, they were three or
four months apart really
put me in a place.
- [Kevin] What are people having
a hard time figuring out that
you wish you could just really
tell people this is what you
need to succeed?
I mean people are looking
to you for like that thing to
tip them over.
- Permission.
- [Kevin] Is it permission?
- It's permission.
People are scared to fail.
You know, one thing
you and I have--
- [Kevin] That's crazy to me.
- Well you just beat me to,
I was about to say the one
thing you and I have in common
in our differences is that.
You are so not scared too.
- [Kevin] Well dude,
you're gonna die.
We'll all be dust in 30 years.
- Yeah, I better
not die in 30 years.
Jesus Christ, this guy.
Thank you, 50's better.
- [Kevin] I'm just
saying like why not, man?
Like why not give it
your all and go crazy, right?
- Because people care
what other people think.
- [Kevin] Who cares?
Everyone's gonna fail.
You're gonna fail.
- Of course!
- [Kevin] I'm gonna fail.
- Of course.
- [Kevin] Like
everywhere we look around,
people have
failed trying new things.
- Of course.
Thanks, man.
- [Kevin] Thanks so much for
being on the show.
- Thank you,
brother. I love you.
- [Kevin] Appreciate it. Yeah.
Alright.
- That was fun.
We'll get together and
just kind of shoot the shit.
You know?
Feel like I'm doing a lot
of one-on-ones and you know,
I still haven't
really, it was funny,
I was thinking about it today
without remembering that we were
doing this today like
when are we going to do
the town hall thing?
But even if I can finally figure
my shit out and do the town hall
thing, I want to
do more of these.
15s, 20s, I just don't think,
I think what's holding back is
I just don't see how were gonna
get to anything
real with 700 people.
You know, tough to ask those
questions that you really want
an answer from but I'm trying to
figure how to scale a little bit
because people are not, I mean,
when I look around the room here
and think about how little time
I've had with some of you like
that's exactly why I'm here.
I think my style of building
businesses is to establish
kindness and culture first.
And so, I think
about it like parenting.
I think you parent your kids in
the first three or four years
and some, most of you or some
of you will get this opportunity.
Very different than you, Misha
is perfectly aligned with the
age of this company.
They were literally
born the same month, right?
We expect a little more from
Misha then we do from Xander
'cause she's seven
and he's four.
("On My Way" by JayTwo)
- [Eva] Do you think if you
didn't get the stuff that you
got with angel investing,
would you have
done things differently?
- [Gary] No, because
that's how I built Wine Library.
Nothing.
- [Eva] But timing wise, you
think you'd be able to do a lot
of the giving back that
you're doing now at this scale?
- [Gary] Yeah, it's
the thing that I did.
It's how I built Wine Library.
I'm just patient.
Like what's
everybody in a rush for?
Like, I promise you
if I asked everybody hey,
do you want to make $10 million
in three years or do you want to
make $50 million and 11?
Some people would
take the 10 in three.
That's fine but I don't know.
I like the 50 in 11 just better.
I think people get confused and
unfortunately I didn't document
this at the time.
So here's something interesting.
I was about to say I think
people get confused 'cause I
wasn't documenting my life and
thoughts when I was actually
being patient in my 20s.
And now, they see it.
What I don't think people
realize is I'm nothing compared
to what I'm gonna be.
So when I'm gonna be the guy.
Like "The".
- Mhmmm.
- Not nice cult status
amongst the smart--
- Sure.
- homies then this
is gonna be interesting.
- Right.
- This is gonna be real
interesting when you know when
I sell a company
for $1.7 billion.
This is gonna be
really interesting when
I buy a brand and flip it.
This is gonna be really
interesting when I make my
I know that I have another
Facebook and Uber in me like
when I make that but
I'm gonna put $5 million into
at a $10 million valuation,
own half of it
and then (mimics explosion).
This is the
interesting in 25 years.
- One of the things I thought,
'cause I've been in the tech
world for all my career, but
I have a lot of friends that
always ask whether or not
I would start my own thing.
Including my former CEO
asked me if I had any desire
to do your own thing some day.
- Yeah, you have such
a confidence kind of vibe
which makes sense.
- But it's funny because
my answer was always no.
- No.
- I think I'm a very, and until
you said it in your content,
I think it really stuck with me,
I'm a very good number two.
- Yeah, I get it, man.
- I love being that.
- So I'm gonna say something
that pisses me off that DRock is
catching this because I've said
it here and there and I don't
think I've, I don't think I'm
gonna be escaping this one.
I secretly wish
I was a number two.
- Why's that?
- It's the best job.
- Mhmmm, yeah.
- You get a lot of
the economics, a lot.
You get a lot, a lot, a lot,
a lot of the perks and
a lot less of the shit.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You're
still number two.
- When you're number one,
you're a professional janitor.
- When you're number one, you're
in the shittiest spot ever.
It devastates me that
my hardwiring forced me
into the narrative.
I'm obsessed with number two.
It's the gig.
It's just great.
You can still impact.
- Yeah.
- You can do so much.
- And there's still
something about not being the
last line of defense.
You still get to look
at somebody else and go.
- We do.
- Yeah.
- And for me, the way I am,
theoretically I wish I was
number two but for me, it's so
funny even though I just made
that huge rant, I could never
look at somebody and say
what are we gonna do? You know?
(laughs) It's funny
but it's a good gig.
It's a good gig and I think
even more interestingly,
I think number three
and four and five.
I mean if you are,
if you can be impactful.
There's people in my company
that are number 57 but have a
lot of influence and
that's a really great gig.
- Mhmmm.
- You know?
But everything's
relative, right?
- That's right.
Yes, that's right, that's right.
- 52 at Facebook, you're
rolling around in more money--
- Oh my God, from a financial
standpoint number 52 at Facebook
is going to make more
than 99.9% of number ones.
- Sure.
- That's why I always remind
people that interact with me,
this is where I think
DRock is very smart.
Been watching
his whole narrative,
like, you got to be smart
when catch a tiger by the tail.
You really do.
- Did you see what
Sheryl Sandberg was saying?
She was just told would you say
no to a seat on a rocket ship?
- Yeah, right. Uh-huh.
- Yeah.
You just take
whichever seat is give to you.
- And I love the
meritocracy of it all.
With the people
that jumped off my ship,
I'm such a son of a bitch
when it comes to the competitive
nature of business.
Like I love them and I feel sad
and I want nothing but great and
I genuinely, genuinely,
genuinely wish they go
on and do bigger.
- Yes.
- Than if they stayed with me.
I really, I really do however,
I'm excited to knowing that
that's probably not
going to be the case and
I can't wait to see them.
- Mhmmm.
- That's why I love business.
Because you can be a good guy
and you can be an assassin at
the same time and if you
know how to balance it you
can really pull it off.
I should be down in like 20, 30.
I'm gonna take the
mic off for now, DRock.
- [DRock] Yep.
("On My Way" by JayTwo)